welcome back to
age 20 special relativity in this video
we talk about galilean transformation so
what is it you're going to do you want
to describe our event p
maybe professor cluj exploding
um it's two different reference frame we
can call one of the reference frame our
laboratory frame
maybe that's the frame in which
professor clutter was stationary it has
an origin and has axis x y and z
and then we have a moving frame which is
moving with a constant velocity
with respect to the laboratory frame
the origin is o prime the axes are x
prime y prime and z prime
all right so now what did we learn from
this let's think about an example
an example most of you have experienced
before is the one where you sit in a
train car and if it's not a train car it
can be a
car or a plane something which is moving
with respect to earth
if you look out of the window
and you know the acceleration is very
very minor
it's often not clear whether or not the
earth the train station or the train car
is moving and so you have
this this kind of
weird feeling that you know i don't know
if maybe the neighboring train started
moving or i'm i'm moving um but what you
want to do here is describe
you sitting in the train car
um you know reading a newspaper uh once
with
within your laboratory frame within the
frame of the train and then you want to
describe the very same events or
sequence of events
in
the frame of the stationary train
station
all right let's look at a specific
example
here again our professor is exploding at
a time
tp
at xp yp and zp
to make this a little bit easier
we define at time t equals zero the
origin of the two frames coincide that
just means that
at the origin we have two clocks two
watches and we make sure that they're
synchronized
right and then you know my watch stays
with me and then there's a second watch
maybe with you um
which
you know
moves along and those are great watches
they're synchronized
you also want to simplify you can always
define the
direction of our coordinate system such
that the velocity
the relative velocity between the two
reference frame is in one specific
direction here i decided to use x i
could have used y and z and i could
rotate them
rotate the coordinate systems or the
relative movement of the coordinate
systems in any way it's just a
simplification here
when i do that i can rewrite this event
p
in the s s
prime frame through the s frame in the
following way so for x we find
that x p is given by x prime p is given
by x p minus v the velocity relative
velocity
i could put a little label x here
times t p
and then for the y coordinates and the z
coordinates there's no change
for the time intuitively you say that
just two watches they run with the same
speed
um meaning that the time in both frames
for the same events are the same
so now i'm asking you if you're watching
this video
um
to find the velocity and acceleration it
might be good to stop and just write
this down
so find the velocity and acceleration of
the s prime of s prime expressed by the
s coordinates let's try to do that
so first we built the derivative
dx prime dt prime which is our velocity
that's the velocity of an object in my
prime frame
and that's given by d dt
i can just
do that here because the times are the
same
um
times x minus vt
that's
x u x the velocity in my s frame minus v
that's really what you expect you just
subtract or add the velocities
if i then build the acceleration i have
to build the derivative of u x prime
which is our acceleration
in the prime frame
um here again i just do this in x
direction because the solution for the y
direction and z direction by trivial so
now i find d u x
dt minus dv dt
now the velocity as we defined between
the two reference frame is constant
therefore this is zero meaning that the
velocity of the accelerations in the two
frames are the same
the accelerations are the same
that means that
the uh forces in the two frames are the
same and that means that the forces
or the accelerations are invariant they
do not change
based on the reference frame i use
so now
coming back to the example we discussed
in our very first lecture
uh your experiment in the train car
as
the velocity
between those two frames
the frame
in your car
or a second frame
are constant there is no way to tell
whether or not your train car is moving
or not
that is only true as long as the
velocities are constant and and and
unchanged constantly
so in summary
in newton's mechanics time
and accelerations are invariant and
therefore also the forces there is no
inertial frame which is above another
one
so you can pick one or you can pick
another one there is no difference in
the descriptions of the physics between
those two frames